hey a lot to get to today we have Alex
Jones and we have a Gerald Morgan is
actually down in Milwaukee where
tomorrow at 7 30 Eastern 8 30 uh sorry
no wait 7 30 Central God's time Satan's
time 8 30 Eastern uh we'll be doing a
live stream of the uh primary debates
you can use the hashtag crowderdebate
stream we'll have drinking game rules
and uh yeah we actually have our own
booth there of course uh being supported
by Rumble where uh the candidates who
have the brass pendulous balls to do so
we'll sit down and give us an exclusive
interview after the performance that's
tomorrow 8 30 Eastern 7 30 God's time
enjoy the show
we'll be covering everything tonight and
I give you my word that will not only be
up to the minute and as good as any of
the Legacy Media Outlets
but better they all have to walk on
eggshells for fear of the tech overlords
removing them we don't have to
viewers are linked together in their
calls they want to know why you give the
power back to the user I think we all
made a mistake in 2016. gasoline prices
are up 60 but this is all the fun I get
to have we're looking forward to the
debate I believe we have a compromised
president
[Music]
Joe said uh may come in hard for
Republicans at first interest you know
he said he was hard no that's what
by the way none of that checks out two
million early votes so we're cap we are
gearing up for 2024 which I believe is
the most important election of our
lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
would I know
[Music]
glad to be with you that's the first uh
first live show of the week today's a
little bit of an a typical week black
and white and the gray shoes went up
yesterday tomorrow we have that debate
stream at 8 30 Eastern so 7 30 Central
that'll be a lot of fun and uh do you
have the drinking game rules there uh
tool man I sure do let's see what they
are drinking game rules for tomorrow you
can play along you drink whenever Trump
is mentioned 2020 January 6 is mentioned
the moderator cuts off or interrupts a
candidate we have a thug life moment or
you finish your drink anytime a
candidate mentions a Democrat other than
Biden well that might be rare so maybe
no alcohol poisoning
uh tomorrow we'll see
what to get to today uh I don't know if
you know this a lot of Americans want us
to be more like Europe that's a trend uh
spoiler alert I don't and then we have
new lockdowns coming uh coming here up
on the horizon Alex Jones called me
about it last week on Friday a lot of
people are covering I said well great
let's let's see how we approach this and
you know maybe we have an investigative
unit where he goes oh yeah that's great
I love that idea and then he talked
about it anyway
so he'll be on the show here later and
we have Gerald as our correspondent uh
today out there in Milwaukee but today
we have both third and fourth chair as I
bring them in when you hear this music
was it new oh that's right
he'll be at Rob's comedy Playhouse
Buffalo New York Friday September 15th
and his show is right here on mug Club
you can watch it Monday Thursday 5 p.m
Nick depaolo how are you sir good how
you doing I'm doing well your your mic
is coming in low on my uh headphones
there is he all right he's fine he's
fine all right test test it why would
you why you decided to go Dom DeLuise is
that how you test your microphone nice
reference what is this 1958 I have no
idea excuse me and then we have a fourth
chair I guess because we have third and
fourth chair here today uh you know
[Music]
also September 16th but he'll be in
Sarasota Florida at Art Ovation uh it
can follow more of his dates at Jim
brewer.com Mr Jim Brewer how are you sir
I'm kid I didn't realize how annoying
that picture was
I think it's good I think it's me still
trying to hold on to something I think
I'm cool inside somewhere you're still
cool because you don't care about being
I really don't that's how I think it
works I really know if I did I'd look
better
could we bring that picture up can I see
it again what's wrong with the picture
look at the me hold it like come on what
am I doing what's the matter with that
you try this you're trying to pick up a
Cub Scout
it's like Sean T from the Insanity
Workout yes oh God
uh by the way we have and uh by the way
Ginger Snap is in here today filling in
uh he's just here to help us as we have
some air support because Gerald is down
we're going to Gerald right now sure but
first off let me ask the question of the
day have you been following this Dylan
Dennis Logan Paul um fiance Fiasco and
if so you know uh what are your thoughts
on it do you think
do you think it's slut-shaming or do you
think that you know it's a fair game if
someone has made their name and brand
off of being a notoriously promiscuous
but let's go really quickly before that
too Gerald in Milwaukee Mr Morgan can
you hear me sir
hi Ken how you doing Stephen but you
sound so formal just tell me what's
happening what's going on there I'm here
to the base oh my God this is exactly
what's going on up here though you've
got foxes you've got every single person
out here they're by the way they're
fixing the roads behind me right before
the day of the debate I'm like ah you
chose now to put some new asphalt down I
really appreciate that no but Rumble has
got a really awesome Booth here you can
see over my shoulder they've got the
debate prep going on right now
um it's going to be a really cool event
tomorrow it's kind of a fun setup out
here but
um I I got to be honest there's not many
more years you're going to get that kind
of a formal debate appearance because
Rumble and streamers and creators are
absolutely changing the way that these
things are going to be consumed and the
questions that will be asked like you
won't have to worry about Ron DeSantis
or Chris Christie or anybody wanting to
do your show the next week as a Creator
you can just ask the real question that
you want to answer to so I'm excited to
be here and I'll try not to be too
formal have you run into Chris Christie
I mean I know you couldn't miss but have
you spent time with them I did frequent
several donut shops there have not been
any sightings of the former New Jersey
governor yet well uh I am holding out
hope okay look in the back room he's
eating the rod though
[Laughter]
I don't know it's not cookie dough Chris
Christie it's not safe that's how you
get salmon
nobody no I can't imagine any person was
out there going gosh you know we need
for 24. yes exactly yeah we need him
like we need Nikki Haley yeah I know
well hey come on now
two boobs are better than zero that's
true
that's true you've got me there I got no
energy I feel like a oh cancer patient
go ahead well don't worry we're gonna we
have some bits about cancer here later
today
I'm not tipping your hand letting you
know that you did get the covet there
last week I did get the covered yes
because I travel I'm still I'm out there
I'm um yeah now it's spreading again and
so we'll be looking at lockdowns of
course as we head into uh you know yeah
we all know that's not gonna happen
again you could it could be a whole new
strain it could be killing babies and
women we're not putting a mask on well
you love half the country or maybe 30
who will and then the other portion of
the country go no we're not doing that
yeah we call those yes pretty
much these are technical terms
all right Gerald uh if you let us know
we'll check back in with you a little
bit later sure my lips are blue I'm here
what's going on I don't know I like how
Gerald said you can see they're
preparing behind us I see two trees
[Laughter]
are they in the basement putting up
traffic columns what are they doing I
don't believe those are arborists now
exactly so one of the first uh this has
been making the rounds here okay uh now
I know that what you're saying before I
mention it but culturally there's some
relevance yes Logan Paul is an idiot to
begin with yes and so is this guy Dylan
Dana so they're set to do this fight in
October okay there's this celebrity
boxing stuff that's been going on uh to
be clear it's kind of a new trend fine I
don't care where you line up on that but
Dylan Dennis has been trolling this guy
Logan Paul's fiance now here's the thing
her name is Nina Nina Agdal
um this has been going back and forth
I'm curious as to where you guys line up
but people think oh you know you're
bringing someone's family I guess fiance
not technically family into it but it
says more about modern relationships and
dating if you have children right now
they should block their ears and not
because of something that's being said
about her but what she says about
herself uh so three two it's not a
trigger warning it's just an
age-appropriate warning because she
she speaks like a dirty pirate I
know where I line up right behind yeah I
knew exactly where Nick was good night
everybody uh here's some videos that
were shared on Twitter from this woman
the fiance and it's become a big topic
only thing better than dessert is sex
would make me eggs and bacon a lot of
bacon and sausage
meant weiner when she said sausage
cooked me dinner again like a good steak
with a good sauce and some potatoes
maybe we'll give you a good sausage and
then after that
you know what happens you talk about
your daddy issues hello I don't really
think penises are that pretty so I
prefer you to hide
casually I sucked in a football stadium
full of people once who hasn't
okay
so look this is one of those things
where now Dylan Dennis has come in and
he's been bringing up he's you know he's
fighting this guy Logan Paul and he's
brought up the fact that she's been with
pretty much every man you know since the
history
going back to Charlotte
hey this is off limits well let me ask
you again comment below do you think
it's off limits when this is she has put
herself out there as a public figure and
her her calling card has been I'm a
model who has sex with lots of guys
uh here is kind of the twist is this
same person a doll she withheld uh sex
and I don't know if it's from moral
Reasons from this guy Logan Paul for an
extended period of time and that's where
kind of the ribbing seems to come in but
this is one of those issues where uh it
just doesn't really make sense and
clearly she's with Logan Paul because
she wants to be famous I think people
need to have an accurate assessment of
what the relationship is like when you
see a guy who's 85 you know he's
shriveled up and I was like Donald what
was him Sterling was it Donald Sterling
Sterling the guy who got in trouble with
his uh his broad who he said something
racist the Clippers no the Clippers the
Donald Sterling Donald strong he was
like you can do whatever just don't
upload on social media and then she
released that recording like she's not
with you because you're a Dapper Dan
it's pretty obvious so here she is now
talking with Logan Paul about not
sleeping with him
you you not
having sex with me for the duration of
time that you did was very important you
thought something was wrong with me I
I'll be honest I thought I did you
talked to Mike about it I said this this
girl's perfect as far as I can tell
there's one unexplored
Venture and I I have reason to believe
that there's probably something wrong
with it because if it's too good to be
true probably is wait it's too good to
be true to be with the woman who slept
with everyone but yourself
that's living the dream how is that too
good to be true well if she's banging
like DiCaprio and stuff you know she's
not a pig she was until she hit 21 and
he kicked her to the curb okay that's
fine so
I'm just saying this is professional
wrestling but in boxing yeah that's all
it is yes it is I'm gonna talk about his
wife cause she's a you call my
wife a how dare you well it's not
his boyfriend says fiance she's not a
with him is she withholding
because of the the fight you know how
they do that yeah I don't think she's I
don't like the Raiders
I don't wanna how weaken your legs Logan
yeah that's
that's nice weekend's lights that's what
I'm talking about tiger I thought that's
why they were gonna go with that no I
don't think so I don't think he's that
thoughtful uh look everyone has their
preferences and we can't fully you know
we can't judge Horrors running around
doing their little behind shake for the
men folk I kind of like her idea but
this is one of those things where look
this is this goes back to the sexual
empowerment of of women where women were
told that they were just a sexually
predatorialism and it's just not true
that's not accurate and now women are
confused in a lot of ways and by the way
men aren't necessarily happy this is not
new men don't want to marry a woman who
sleeps with everybody sure they like
breasts sure they like naked ladies but
that doesn't mean that you mean anything
to them and I get it people think it's
going a little too far with Dylan and
he's you know a scumbag but it's a
scumbag attacking a scumbag over a woman
being a floozy should I know this Dylan
guy is he famous you wanna work I think
he won Worlds at Jiu Jitsu once and then
kind of disappeared he's really really
good at remaining relevant while doing
nothing oh so I'll see him on celebrity
chef next week
[Laughter]
um but he wasn't being mean about it he
was just putting I liked how he did it
he put a clip of her saying dirty stuff
and he just put interesting yeah well
then he put up all of these pictures
with her in like the entire you know
Raiders offensive line or whatever it is
done I was up all night
but I will say this like you see a lot
of guys do and this is one thing where
guys get confused you'll get the guys
who will say like oh they're traditional
males or sort of the manosphere but then
they go well it's really hard to find a
good woman these days who's traditional
but then they they root around looking
for women like that what do you expect
when you're you're finding someone who's
posting their breasts on Instagram like
they'll say these things but then they
they put themselves in a box where they
can only find these women this is not
going to work for relationships this is
not going to be a good future here for
people in the United States women aren't
happy men aren't happy and you know what
it starts with they're being a
respectable man and not being you know a
lying
the feminist ruined it yeah to be clear
I don't know if she's a liar
it's a great theater yeah it is but it's
it is something like this is an example
think about this for young women where
it's like I mean where else did he go
Kamala Harris right she's the most
powerful woman I guess
she became famous by sleeping with
anyone who could give her a job
well isn't that the trend of our great
cut think of every TV show how many
shows was Kardashians didn't that show
didn't that kick off with a what a naked
video yeah yeah that's the new hey
that's the new pilot
show his sex tape and we'll get you yeah
that's equivalent about the script yeah
exactly yeah the spec script yeah
here's the show idea
we'll buy it
the campaign I have a development deal
from Warner Brothers really it looks
like a webcam and a ring light I don't
think that that's exactly it's
experimental it's not guaranteed to air
all right that brings us by the way to
uh something else where we're discussing
a geopolitics
over a thousand people are still missing
of course uh tragic thoughts and prayers
and I mean I can't imagine uh the death
toll rate is over 114 I think now in
Maui a thousand missing so a thousand
people missing have they checked the
beaches yeah well you would think
be the first place I would look but
sometimes sometimes it's not the most
obvious place that was I I can't believe
you couldn't do more damage drop in a
nuclear bomb that was horrendous yeah it
is it's the deadliest uh deadliest
wildfire in modern history as far as I
know but I'm not a wildfire Aficionado
you can correct me
um so former Vice President Joe Biden
finally visited
after coming back from vacation uh while
the fires were raging and this brings us
to this weekend Biden if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump and you ain't black I don't
want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home to make a
long story short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat we were insured
we did not have any problem but being
out of our home
for better part of a year
was difficult
you guys catch the boots out here
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black that's some hot ground man
he was just new boot goofing do you
remember you remember when George W bush
got in trouble for doing a flyby in his
helicopter with Katrina can you imagine
if she's ground's hot
George does not care about that yes I do
I'm just saying it's hot ground I mean
it was way hotter like two weeks ago but
yeah
I mean I lost my convertible yeah my cat
yeah it's not like a Norm Macdonald I
almost lost my convertible he said it's
not even I almost lost last night
I thought I didn't have ah yeah I used
to have a cat
it came back you know and now I got a
cat again so
okay that's what I'm trying to say
and this guy's go people think he's
going to win I mean of course it's not
going to be the nominee no way oh you
really don't you think it's gonna be
good not gonna be the nominee who is I
don't know but it's not that schmuck I'm
telling you it's not gonna be him I will
put my life on
careful Nick I really don't put your
life I'm 61. I'm gonna go tomorrow I'm
catching covet every three weeks like
I'm
laughs
pangolins what are they
England's pangolins what is combined a
penguin with the Chinese
I have no idea what you're talking about
I don't need it there's a late night you
wanna say something there Jim good I'll
just say my my favorite part of that
video was watching the Hawaiians behind
him the one guy at the ukulele really
looked like he wanted to just smash him
yeah
he's forced up there he knows his
family's gonna give him hell when it's
over yeah
I think I was my favorite guy just stand
in the background that's the guy who won
American Idol yeah
all right hey by the way if that wasn't
disrespectful uh enough here he is he
could be looking at his phone but let's
go with he was falling asleep
oh God
we are a community that relies on family
on Ohana
blood or by French
leader of the Free World
burned up
my daughters
were you about to say something in their
Lane earlier I thought no no I don't
know he's just here making sure we have
the air support uh Hey look
not a fan let's go back to Gerald here
really quickly at the the rumble
headquarters there the booth that we
have for the debate stream tomorrow
which is going to be more lively than
today what do you have there Gerald uh
so I think what he was doing Stephen was
praying so every time he goes to follow
say hey man hey man yeah that's a good
cupboard I like Nick's point though I
don't know if he's going to be the
candidate either right so oh come on no
I really listen nobody's excited about
him just like so many of the other
candidates that are here outside of the
top guys like Vivek and and some of the
other guys DeSantis obviously make kind
of a big impression on people but nobody
wants Joe Biden to run for president
especially not going and saying stupid
stuff by the way I love their response
when he was driving in it was literally
Fu they were saying he's yeah finally
after so many days and I feel like
nobody likes this guy Hawaii but no one
liked him when he ran before for Crime
there's nothing new why would they all
of a sudden look first of all this is
something new oh sorry what do you think
what new stranded
no there is a new story to cover coming
right again good Lord no but I think the
thing that's new is that they've seen
him for four years and they've seen how
terrible he is at the job and there's no
way he's going to make it another four
five six years into this and I think
they're looking around going okay how do
we get out of this deal who else is
there that can run I really really do I
don't know if they'll be able to do it I
just think that that's what they're
trying to do right now with everything
they have in them Gavin Newsom can't
come soon enough for them that and he
didn't win last time well there is that
yeah these are Minor Details
in doubt how dare you question that
you know what though I want to toss that
comment below hit the like button by the
way if you're watching and if you're
watching on YouTube head on over to
rumble and watch it there uh that's what
we do in the Stream tomorrow on Rumble
do you think that it's not going to be
it's not going to be Biden Newsome I
don't I I just don't think they can do
that change right now that 180. he's not
gonna he's declining so fast
he's not gonna I'm telling you I mean I
just I feel like I'm I feel like people
are forgetting how an ft was in the last
election he's a sneeze away from in
his pants on national TV he's already
telling you I guarantee you he's done
that yeah
I think he's gonna win do you I think
he's got it I think he's got it hands
down that's how that's how demonic they
are they're like listen
let the post come in we're not having a
debate we're not even say anything we're
just gonna announce we won again and
watch out yeah I even if that happens I
still say I'm telling you yeah yeah I'm
telling you I don't know and we'll go I
can't believe it you know what I don't
have a strong enough opinion on this
where I I still would think it's it's
Biden if I had to bet but I I understand
your point I'm curious to see what
people say there in the comments
genuinely I don't know if this is if
it's a 50 50 split or if there's 20 of
the people out there who think it's
going to be Newsome I mean I've heard
this floated I know that Patrick David
has talked about it that's what he
believes I don't know though I just
think that would be really tough that
would be tough to do and not be seen as
an admission of weakness for the party
going into a national election can
Matthew McConaughey play that character
for that long
but the thing is is exactly right
if I do sneeze I my pain
but all I see in the middle of the road
are dead armadillos what
is it's a Cadillac commercial who cares
uh it's Lincoln get it right get your
subpar American same thing come on
either way they can go in a straight
line and rattle all right Gerald we'll
check back in with you unless there's
something that I'm missing let's go on
to America versus Europe or as I say uh
uh the better I mean America versus
lesser than
so you you've probably heard this take
right now it's been coming from younger
generations and someone was raised in
Canada I just think people don't realize
they're so unaprinted I know every
generation says this they're so
unappreciative of what they have in the
United States where they say hey why
can't we be more like Europe young
people saying they're going to move to
Europe now I think we're better than
Europe that's why we left but I was
raised in Canada where there was this
jealousy complex the United States and
people would always act as though
Americans had it wrong a big argument
they would use is when you travel abroad
they don't like Americans well no one
likes number one draft pick the Cutaway
right of course they're going to be
angry and jealous so let's watch a quick
just so you can see this quick reel so
you don't take my word for it believe
Your Lying Eyes liners of course all
references after this we're going to do
a claim in truth a fact check uh
references available at
letterscutter.com all people beforehand
used to think like the US was like very
cool and this really lovely place to go
to but I feel like everyone just thinks
it's dangerous and that they don't care
about their citizens there's all these
shootings going on like their health
care is horrible their schools tell us
about your stabbings
go home in shape
yes in Germany you feel like German
people have a positive view of Americans
or not really no okay so more negative
but you know who has a negative view of
Germany historically yeah the world yeah
what are they known for scatterological
the world war is under your belt that's
right all of them
[Laughter]
the ones that we've had that was you so
let's go through this let's go through
the claims and the truth and these are
just sort of sometimes colloquialisms or
sort of stereotypes the first claim they
make is that Americans are stupid
all right that's a very generalized
claim but here's the truth and you can
measure this this can be Quantified just
go to the airport and look around
they're right well that is I really do
especially in New York in L.A yeah well
if you go by TSA you're going to think
this is a nation of fat dumb
look I think it's idiocracy I do get
that
we're not sending our brightest to TSA
my point is if I arrived at the
international uh whatever is TSA what's
the international arrivals I have no
idea I don't know what it's called the
point is it's rough here's the truth
America okay the United States of
America no one else even compares to the
contributions that we've made to the
world right uh at large but even if you
look at what we have today the top
scientists the United States is 100
sorry has 617 out of the top thousand
right UK is second place with 95. with
more than six times the top scientists
the next closest the UK we have more
than all of the EU combined you want to
look at universities if you want to
measure it through Intelligentsia 19 out
of the top 25 universities are in the
United States we have the most Nobel
Prize winners we're ranked number one
with 400 Noble Lords UK number two with
138 that's less than half if you're not
a mathematician yourself Germany number
three with 111. we have the most college
grants that's not even close we have a
higher percentage of the population with
two or four year degrees vocational
programs than any EU country and not to
mention how many Innovations the United
States has 5.9 million patent grants
that have been issued between 1980 to
2021 that's more than the top 10 EU
Nations combined and I don't know if you
know this I don't know if any of you are
history Buffs but throughout our very
short history where we left the world's
greatest superpower one century to
become the only world superpower The
Next Century we've come up with more
than a few convenient knickknacks
[Music]
sorry we'll do better
was that a traffic cone yeah
hell yeah it's the little things
it kind of amazes me that no one else
even thought of it that's right hey what
should we do all these kids are getting
hit I don't know put a cone up I know
that one really jumped out at me it's
kind of like when they came up with
basketball was a guy's name like John
Smith whitest it was in Canada Smith
James Naismith that's right and they
they were using Peach baskets and so
someone have to get up on a ladder and
take the ball out of the basket yeah I
always heard Springfield Massachusetts
well the guy was Canadian I know that
maybe he was in Mexico that's what it
happened and then they're like this is
really inconvenient let's cut a small
hole in the basket so we can poke it out
with a broom yes and then finally they
created a chain system with a pulley
like oh we're gonna put in a chain that
we pull and it'll pop the ball out until
someone just said why don't you just cut
a hole in the basket big enough for the
ball to go through
I'd like it with a chain now in the NBA
yeah yeah at least that'll be hilarious
you don't even need to pull it they're
all like seven foot five
but just sometimes like it's the obvious
answer by the way we have also the most
millionaires in the United States by far
four times as many as second place right
when we're talking about China which by
the way they haven't necessarily come by
that honestly 10 times as many uh as in
the highest EU country which is France
which surprised me so this is one of the
Americans are idiots okay but we're more
educated we do better as far as our
income and uh of course we also have
more wealthy people than anywhere else
in the world and we have invented more
than any society has really in the last
ah call it half a millennia then again
Joe Biden's your president I know when
we go along with lockdowns and we still
wear mask at airports and we're the
fattest human beings in the world
education doesn't mean you're really
that smart these days
that used to be a positive yeah yeah but
now it's almost a negative exactly I'm
just saying if you do go around Europe
or anywhere outside listen if we're
hanging out and we ask what do you what
do you think of crowder and 10 people go
he said this he's that there's something
to be said if they're all saying the
same thing when you start try it's
something to be said when the world is
starting to look at you as you're the
dumb asses of the world you're the
fatsos of the world right and we don't
really trust you anymore that that's
it's not funny but it's alarming to me I
don't remember them being in love with
us forever you said when you're number
one they want to knock you off the hill
I mean even when the French sent their
people during the revolution it was
begrudgingly like all right we'll come
over I will help yes it's a big
inconvenience I mean it is a problem
though it is a problem of over abundance
I'd rather us have the option to be fat
than be starving the problem is when you
praise obesity you end up with lizzo
which by the way if she's so beautiful I
don't know why people get mad when we do
the side-by-side pictures yeah she's
she's ripped she's yes she's very brave
do we do have a problem definitely in
the United States of obesity by the way
hit the rumble button if you're watching
a rumble smash that Rumble button and uh
I don't know if we've probably had the
YouTube uh dump button at some point day
a little bit I would have to go to a
mall or an airport spend a year in
Europe looking around to see because
when I'm at the airport I go now I'm
seeing why they say that yeah and every
person not just five pounds overweight
and they're in sweatpants I will tell
you this you know my you know I
sometimes go to a community pool they
have like slides and stuff with little
ones we need every single girl between
the ages of 13 and 18. has been
completely overweight now it's not the
case with the young men we're also the
only country where the girls don't know
if they're girls anymore so we're not
the only country that's Europe too no
but we're deaf Europe heavy pushers
[Music]
thank you
very damn close I feel like it's
something translation yeah now all the
girls are overweight I've noticed that
and then a lot of young men aren't you
know why because guys are going to bust
their friends balls but yeah you fed
some of it what are you thinking and no
girl's gonna want you don't get to
declare yourself beautiful as a guy the
girl's like I'm I'm hot I Don't Give A F
I don't care I'm hot as well you're
always looking at public pool in Detroit
[Laughter]
is this thing alive all right
uh here's another claim that they'll
make though that they are absolutely
wrong about is that American Health Care
sucks and we've done many segments on
this the first undercover video I ever
did was uh you know Canadian Health Care
uh where I did it I went undercover with
back then they didn't really have GoPro
so I'd have to put like uh you know I
have to put like a DSLR camera in a
trucker hat
it was really really tough to do so
American Healthcare sucks okay they'll
say that here's one thing they only use
one study when they translate American
Health Care is worse than insert
whatever other country here and when you
look at that study we're right neck and
neck with Colombia and ranked above us
as Cuba so that's a study when you look
at these International Studies that are
really just conducted based on people
who like their own health care first off
you're dealing with communist Nations
where I don't know if people are
answering those those that polling data
accurately second people don't know any
better so they say yeah I I used to
think that Canadian Healthcare wasn't
all that bad until I buried my third or
fourth relative for causes that would
have been entirely survivable here in
the United States so that's their claim
American Health Care sucks let me let me
rattle through this here the truth uh no
it's not even close so your single
biggest statistical
um indicator whether you will survive a
serious disease
if you had to pick one out of a hat okay
what can I do to increase my living in
the United States rich or poor by the
way so breast cancer prostate cancer
your rate of dying
is more than twice that of the United
States if you live in the UK or Germany
double
now big reason breast cancer is a huge
indicator is because you know it's very
survivable now but it's very fast moving
so the quality of care and being able to
get it quickly determines whether you
live or die there are more Europeans
right now who are waiting a month to see
a specialist in the United States U.S is
27 France 36 percent Sweden 52 Norway 61
percent they're waiting more than a
month to see a specialist we rank first
in medical science technology a to the
top 10 medical universities in the
United States and one other thing that
people don't understand hey one thing
when they say hey socialized Healthcare
is great and it's true by the way they
have cheaper drugs in Canada they have
cheaper drugs in here because we
subsidize them we front the costs we pay
the bill we here in the United States
right all medical Innovation comes out
of the United States here and then these
people by the way don't have to defend
their own borders hey Canada you'll have
your socialized Healthcare okay one
thing let's change it protect your own
country
go
enjoy your social programs
a propeller plane with a shotgun it
doesn't constitute an Air Force
here's another clinic to make
but the European lifestyle is superior
now we're getting more cultural uh well
that's just dumb
[Laughter]
this is one thing have you guys noticed
they talk about how Europe is like an
art culture it's a Leisure culture and
it's true that we work too much in the
United States there's been no great art
to come out of Europe in the last 150
200 years
you would think for a country that
subsidizes it they'd have all the
greatest art in the world
in any medium whether it's film whether
it's paint why are so many other great
artists disproportionately American
I know John Wayne Gacy
I could we do well the world was his
canvas yes it was some would say we did
have Bob Ross right did we did yes we
did yeah
it wasn't like a sniper in Vietnam Bob
Ross no he wasn't a sniper but yeah
that's where he started painting in the
military when he was bored at night
everybody this that that that Roma comes
up about everything John Denver killed
more people yeah yeah they said about uh
Mr Rogers was another one Gong Show guy
he's interested he's an interesting
there yeah no that that way he's a legit
uh we'll get into that later yeah on my
club
[Laughter]
we subsidize all of Europe the United
States right that's the truth right we
SP for example
if we didn't subsidize all of Europe on
health care but we also do it directly
as it relates to defending their Nations
so the US half of NATO GDP by the way is
contributed to by the United States
right
um well sorry I should say half is
supposed to be the United States but we
actually pay well over 70 percent of the
combined defense expenditures think
about that for a second you have other
NATO Nations Donald Trump was the first
person to ever say anything about this
they don't even meet the two percent GDP
spending Mark and you know who stands to
gain the lease for NATO us we're not
even on the continent I know what you're
saying but I'm saying you know we do
have some ability to protect ourselves a
little bit more I would say that for
example people in the EU benefit more
from the United States contribution than
we do from Britain than we do from any
other nations in NATO so you have the
United States we contribute 3.52 percent
of GDP to Nato the EU average is not
even two it's 1.75 percent the eu's
richest country Germany 1.5 1.5 percent
is what they contribute well yeah of
course you can have a bunch of free
you don't pay for your own defense and
you don't even pay for the nation
surrounding you who agreed to
collectively pay for each other's
defense also it's why socialism doesn't
we can't even do it with NATO
we can't even collectively foot the bill
for the security after the world almost
ended
Ukraine by the way I don't agree with
this 135 billion for the United States
EU 86 billion that's all of them
combined when you're talking about these
things well I just don't again we're fat
I get it
well we have to relax that's output in
the rest of the world yes right outside
of that outside of being fat anything
where does Europe get it right
why would you move to Europe uh topless
beaches well that's true but you can get
that that's a good point right Jimmy's
you can get it in Florida Brazil you
can't but over there you know I'm saying
there's actual yeah and I'm saying real
tits they're not as obese right
and what and this is something else
that's important to Europe they save all
this money were they spending it okay so
Europe they spend a third less by the
way in research and development in the
United States and Japan
um what they do is end up taking
American innovation for pennies on the
dollar it's not even close and by the
way they're way poorer the Europeans
than Americans just because the average
European citizen our wages continue to
grow while European wages shrinking and
they were growing even faster under
Donald Trump as president the average EU
country far more poor than every single
United States state with the exception
of Mississippi and Idaho I know Stephen
but three-hour lunches yes
gonna say
wine
[Music]
back to work do you want to no I don't
want to well let's not let's just go
home let's just go home make some bread
and by the way do you know what their
solution is you know what their solution
is in Europe you're like oh man we
really we're poor yeah they want to
increase American tourism
this comes from the Wall Street Journal
on the Mediterranean island of uh how do
you pronounce this here Lane Mallorca
mayorka okay I wanted to make sure I was
like my mayor
um
businesses are lobbying for more flights
to the United States to increase the
number of free spending American
tourists said Maria Frontier president
of the mayorkra Chamber of commerce's
Tourism commission and at the same time
they're demanding
that more Americans have Visas so they
want to increase tourism to help the
quality of life for their citizens
because they're poor but at the same
time they just can't help themselves
from setting up more red tape to prevent
that from happening so let's do the math
here Europeans hate Americans but they
want more American
[Music]
so we're footing the bill right that
pretty much to have that right is that
American dollars is it Euros yes
Europe sucks that's the point
yep pull up the Phillips curve go ahead
and move
and by the way they also have a
demographic crisis right around the
corner you were talking about this uh uh
gender snap because you love Asian women
I do yeah true what's the demographic
crisis you're talking about so everyone
points to Japan and South Korea and
China is the super aging societies but
actually Germany and Italy are two of
the fastest aging societies so basically
within the next uh I don't know
generation they're going to be making
the retirees work into their 90s just to
support the people at the bottom because
there's no social safety nets that are
going to exist
so they're screwed so these kids move
there now it's almost like they have the
worst timing well yeah let them go yeah
it's like buying after the game stop did
you say he loves aging or Asians Asians
Asians he also loves aging
yeah I thought I missed her yeah no he
exclusively likes Asian women older ones
Asian ones do you like older women older
aging agents you could probably get away
with a 40 year old 60s it's pretty good
yeah
under the right well we have the same
issue here by the Social Security it's
just that it's accelerated in Europe
because of the population problem but
here when you look at the retirees per
average worker it's insane that Social
Security is referred to as anything
other than a Ponzi scheme it's not
possible to sustain we just grab money
from somewhere else but you're welcome
baby boomers
who are footing the bill for the rest of
you and at some point you just have to
rip off that Band-Aid you traveled
enough have you spent a lot of time in
Europe Nick uh yes Buffalo Cleveland
and the not a lot of time but I've been
to Italy and um
from Germany to get to Afghanistan I was
in Frankfurt at the airport for an hour
um not a lot no not a lot you've
traveled quite a bit yeah yeah yeah I
you know there's some areas I liked yeah
I I don't have a desire to live in any
of them yet no what about Tanzania I
would live in Tanzania yeah because you
want to be off the grid I want to be off
the grid yeah there's something
appealing about it yeah in the middle of
nowhere no lights no sound I would like
a slice of pizza once a while yeah but
outside of that do they not have it
there I don't know about Tanzania if
they're not a big pizza place not a big
pizza place no original rays
no but the bread is good it's the bread
the rest of it's very uh mediocre double
Point Monday it's really really big deal
double appointment is it a really big
deal though is it actually it's just a
sandwich you guys keep going can you
guys let me know what the Jersey Mike's
Fascination I don't get it I just told
you what it is it's the bread absolutely
well then move to Europe for the love of
Christ I didn't say I liked it I'm just
saying it what people like about it it's
the bread yes you always have to be
contrarian Nick I'm just trying to keep
this thing moving from breast cancer
hey can we bring up actually the Fox
News saying let's since we have time the
Fox News unless Gerald wants to come
back in the DeSantis uh article I'm
trying to get Alex up now okay but let's
bring in uh if they can bring it up the
Fox News article that they were they
wrote this this puff piece under Santas
we were talking about this this morning
uh gingersnap where it's like oh does
Santa's surging ahead in uh in Iowa
and they say and DeSantis has a higher
favorability amongst Republican voters
than Donald Trump 66 to 65. I'm going by
wrote here I think I have that right and
they said there are more people who have
Ron DeSantis as their first second or
likely voting Choice uh than any other
candidate yeah but hold on a second is
he their first choice it's not even
close what is he 30 points behind this
is minimum yeah yeah this is how you
know it's propaganda exactly like just
report it accurately tell me who's
winning the poll they're going to the
dark side yeah quick they're very
transparent about it he is he is the
choice of more people as far as if you
include first second third or dead last
more people pick Ron descent well who's
first that's Donald Trump by double
digits yeah I have the quote here if you
want it oh yeah let's bring up the quote
so it says uh DeSantis is also the first
choice second choice or being actively
considered by 61 of likely caucus goers
just slightly behind the 63 63 percent
of respondents who said the same for
Trump no other candidate has broken out
of single digits oh wow good for him
good for him and then how far is he
behind there so the very next paragraph
says overall Trump garnered 42 support
as the Top Choice in the new poll and uh
leading DeSantis by 23 points who only
garnered 19 okay so I was off by seven
by 23 points I've never heard that use
as a metric he Ron DeSantis is he's more
so the choice either first or second or
people would consider him boy you have
to do some mental gymnastics for that
and by the way if you like this I like
this I think he's a great governor too I
think he probably would be a great
president obviously compared to this guy
want to be clear but it is remarkable
when you look at how in the tank a place
like Fox News just do you just don't lie
about it just say your team to Santas
just be honest about it and they just
said they're not going to have any Trump
surrogates honestly they won't have any
Trump surrogates at the debate and this
is something else too you know you think
about it Donald Trump with the debate
how could he possibly do a debate uh and
it not be a liability considering the
current indictment right they would ask
him right that's all he'd get questions
and if he would say that he couldn't
answer they would say Donald Trump
refuses to answer questions why even
show up to them it really is a no-win
situation I don't think there's a world
in which he could do this debate and it
not be used against him in court or him
follow the court orders right now and it
not be used against him in the court of
public opinion you guys can comment but
like it makes sense now that being said
if he wasn't being indicted do I think
he would have showed up to debate anyway
probably not
he could have just go I can't answer
because the investigation has gone on as
we speak and yeah he could say he keeps
saying that like the prosecutor yes but
that's what they would ask him right I
know they would say well that's the
thing he would still win he's going to
win the nomination and he would still
win if he was up there going I can't
answer it I can't answer I can't wait
yeah what about say that Jim it's oh yes
it is any question any debate ask him
any questions just gonna go come on yeah
yeah come back yes are We Done Yet yeah
come back so what about because you know
I can't talk about it you know I can't
talk about it but of course you know I
can't that's why I asked the question
well look I'm just no excuse me excuse
you have to stop speaking shut your lips
and listen I'm 23 points ahead that's a
lot of points that's a lot of points
more points how many and then just
answers would say ah well yeah I just oh
really yeah how how many points are you
ahead DeSantis not counting the 23 here
behind
he'll just make it about the polls and
then it becomes this momentum and of
course it shouldn't only be about the
polls but I don't see how he could
possibly do this debate Paul's don't
reflect what people thinking it shapes
what they're thinking yeah exactly thank
you very much that's on my headstock
you and Frank Luntz
handsome guy here oh he pulls off the
Jerry Seinfeld sneakers really well with
his suits uh do we have Alex Jones do we
have him here ready to go
okay so yeah we're working on well let
me lead into this segment before we
bring in Alex Jones because Alex Jones
is now again right
so uh he called me last week and he said
hey they're going to go into new
lockdowns
uh starting uh I believe he said October
I don't remember the exact timeline but
then he said he was going to keep a lid
on it until he got and then he spoke
about it anyway so look love Alex Jones
impulse control not Chief amongst his uh
his his strongest qualities uh but
here's the thing before
well he called me before this happened
actually now since he called me I
believe it was Wednesday or Thursday now
we're seeing coveted restrictions being
implemented uh across the board in a lot
of places so it turns out he's at least
partially right to only time will tell
if he's fully right here we have I
believe this is a clip from NBC kovid is
making a comeback this summer so many of
us would like to leave it in the past
but cases are once again on the rise so
when will new booster shots roll out
someone wrote that lead in and he was
happy with it kovid is making a comeback
this summer just when you thought it was
safe to go back to the voting booth
everything he said someone wrote it was
like that's great let's lose let's use
this yeah who's
who's buying this who's still going uh a
lot of people a lot of people
can't we just leave them behind at this
point I should like to they're they're
victims of war it's I mean it's nothing
we could do they're casualties send them
to Europe send them Europe yeah
except Sweden because I won't feel safe
there there's no way they're going to
pull this off you don't step away I
don't know they'll be actual it's you
thought it got ugly the first time now
that we know it's a lie you want
to see some fights on planes and stuff
exactly well yeah but if you want to
just go to Spirit
they have like full-time TMZ reporters
for world star on spirit
is a lot of fun yeah uh so Lionsgate
Mass mandate now
and of course the first people to do it
are what Hollywood yeah it's just gonna
say yeah that's always been the history
of California by the way they they
grabbed on hold to that new age
psychology in the 50s yeah and they
because it I call it West Coast stupid
yes that's what I call it it's we have a
segment on my show west coast
stupid I don't know what it is why are
they closer to the communism explain the
history and why that's because
you're stupid and cowed into stuff you
have a concentration of Communists in
the entertainment industry and then of
course in higher education as well a lot
of great a lot of higher you know a lot
of universities there are in California
and of course you have the entire
entertainment industry and a lot of
media there and there's a there was a
proactive concentrome McCarthy wasn't
wrong about everything no there was a
Red Scare in the industry for sure you
just you know got a little overzealous I
kind of liked it
um and they're all in the colors of blue
that's right yeah interesting yeah
Rutgers hmm wait what are you saying I'm
starting to see where Rutgers and
Georgetown are going to start this new
Mass mandate they all are
by coincidence Bluey States Oh I thought
you were talking about the logo the
color blue yeah like is this an
Illuminati very Bluey States that's blue
very blue very blue so August 20th you
have Morris Brown College Now Matt Smith
Morris Brown not Morris but what will we
do I get them against Ohio State third
week
they're plus 79 and they're bringing
back social distancing too not just the
mask manage but social like that is so
severe Rutgers Georgetown like you were
talking about they're going to continue
with mask mandates in addition by the
way to a vaccine mandate by the way the
same people who go around and my
body my choice the same dumbass students
people are dropping dead
you conspiracy theorists you can't prove
it's from that how dare you I know and
misinformation yes and you just go to
the insurance companies the actuaries
have figures go we've never seen a spike
like this yeah starting in 2021 it goes
but the last three weeks I've read about
like a young female called you off the
dropping dead it was a basketball
[Music]
foreign
thank you
point in time no you're absolutely right
though but with the vaccine here's the
thing if we want to talk about the
science for example we got suspended
you're allowed to talk about this now by
the way you're welcome mug Club you can
join up gladoscredit.com you're now
allowed to question election results
you're now allowed to discuss the MRNA
vaccine why because we've suspended
countless times for doing so and they
can't ban all of you if you want to
follow the science isn't it interesting
for example when we quoted the CDC that
far more infants far more toddlers die
annually from the flu than covet now
that's not to say that covet is not
deadly for older people obese people the
immunocompromise I understand that no
one is saying that it's not real no one
is saying that those people aren't more
at risk but wouldn't it be interesting
to study the virus and say why is it
that younger people what is it about
their immune system specifically where
they are not as affected by this whereas
they are by the common flu that comes
around every single year Same by that
same token wouldn't it be interesting to
say well hold on a second why is it that
the MRNA injection doesn't affect older
people who are more affected by the
virus it seems as substantial actually
as younger healthy males why are they
the ones more likely to encounter
complications with any other
you would look at these side effects and
the demographics who experience them
more and you would make that information
remain publicly available if you want to
follow the science these patterns are
interesting I don't know why they
wouldn't be to epidemiologists to
biologists but instead you are precluded
from researching the science old pitbull
get sick and die more young people don't
young people young healthy males for
some reason more complications with the
vaccine old people don't that's
interesting why don't we know they
follow the science until they hit
something that doesn't go with their
narrative yeah that's where the science
stops yeah right there yeah it's just a
fat asian guy eating a bat
sorry when I say Asian Chinese that was
that was racist it's only the Chinese
sweet bets not the Asian well that's hey
Raw it's okay very disappointed we're
all adults here it's gonna be fine I'm
disappointed in myself do we have Alex
Jones uh here on the uh call all right
so now we're going to bring him on uh
you know him you love him he's the OG
let's go to Alex Jones
[Music]
all right Mr Jones can you hear me can
you see me sir
loud and clear all right and the show of
course is Alex Jones 2.0 Fridays at 12
p.m Eastern on mug club now you called
me last week Alex I was telling him
about this about the new lockdowns going
into effect and then I said well look do
we need to keep this under our hat for a
little bit and you said well maybe we
will and then you you know you blew the
lid off of it anyway which I'm grateful
for because now people are aware but
ever since you've done that we now see
these happening with Studios and with
higher education tell people what it is
here you're inside uh Source or I guess
your inside information what is being
planned as far as lockdowns and when
well I like your audience
[Music]
they just
don't care
170 million to Ukraine 700 to people in
Maui Hawaii so I get this call and I've
actually gotten it on Tuesday evening
but I had so many messages I wasn't
listening to until Thursday uh in my
office and I know this person for 20
years and they're high up in the
transportation system of the TSA
it's actually agency above them and so I
call them up and they said hey I'm in
town let's go meet so I went and met him
and they said listen they called in the
managers this is going to happen middle
of September they're going to try to
make all the TSA workers and workers in
airports where I'm in mid-october the uh
oh Biden's going to try to bring back uh
mask in the airports and on planes but I
said well that's insanely unpopular
what's their excuse they said well this
new variant out of Canada that they say
is so bad and Hospital numbers are up so
you're going to see a rollout
sometime in September of all this and
that's what we've been told so then I
got on the phone called a few other feds
I know one of them answered with the
border patrol they said yeah we've been
told over restrictions are coming back
next month as well then that they'll be
phased in so then I went to a computer
and typed in lo and behold hospitals in
New York were already saying put the
mask back on starting next week I saw
reports of colleges already doing it so
yeah I go on my show Friday I talk about
it at 11 A.M Central and then by five
o'clock that night on the Nightly News
everywhere all the stations rolled out
Kobe's back restrictions may be needed
again the BBC the London Guardian uh the
Globe and Mail and all the public
[Music]
thank you
PPE of the preparedness items record
levels of that now being purchased for
September and October uh by the Obama
excuse me bite Administration uh but you
repeat yourself pouring in where they're
actually trying trying this also the
Journal of Jama came out and said that
they're going back to mask into social
distancing and the hospitals being
overwhelmed in all the same crap
definitely can I ask you something who
benefits from this if it happens this
September and October right it would
seem that it would behoove them to try
and place this if they're if what you're
discussing here if we're discussing
something surreptitious or something
nefarious I guess I should say it would
seem that they would want to plan this
for the general election why do you
think they would be doing this so soon
again Stephen I find this hard to
believe I'm not saying it's even going
to happen I didn't think they launched
Their Fear campaign this quick right
truly added a lot of validity to to what
we broke I mean it's gotten tens of
millions of views on Twitter you name it
alone this is a big story because people
are obviously as your crew is saying are
are rejecting this but remember what
they did last time they start the
lockdowns about a third of the way into
they create the fear and then they say
okay we've got the vaccine they now say
they've got a vaccine ready in
mid-september that was announced on
Saturday magically just when the TSA was
told the mass go back on so they've got
a new variant booster they say everyone
needs to take and there'll be a new
variant booster every year that was
announced uh by the CDC by the FDA by
all the different Talking Heads on on
the Sunday news shows show who stands
the game well last time they used it to
disrupt the 2020 uh election you know
obviously I mean they use it to to to
disrupt into 2022 yeah and they've just
done this basically
over and over again so it'll take them
time I I don't think they'll ever get
back to complete control but at the blue
cities and in the swing States and the
blue States they're going to be able to
bring back the mail-in ballots right
which again is now uh only a year out or
so and so they know exactly what they're
doing this as perfect timing and and I
wanted to bring this out have a big
news coverage of it and then get
Governors and legislatures and members
of Congress to say no not this time
instead of us just receiving right the
incremental only 14 days to slow the
spread saying no no no not so fast I
didn't know that five hours six hours
after I broke it they would launch their
propaganda campaign so that was perfect
because everybody's saying is Jones
right about this he's been right about a
lot and then boom they launched exactly
what I was warning a little earlier than
I was told I'm kind of I got to say
though Alex you are off the bridge I'm
kind of surprised that any of the feds
would talk to you about this though at
this point like I would say is this
because there are people who you think
still actually care in the federal about
our state of Freedom are these the
people who you talk with because I would
imagine they would immediately go well
Alex Jones is obviously uh going to be
incredibly upset with the idea of
lockdowns
well I've known this Transportation
official for 22 years I'm not going to
get into how I know him but they once
lived in Austin they don't now and so
I've known them I've known them their
family I've been to dinner with them
probably 20 times so I mean I know this
person I know they're not a BS or good
and they're you know a degreed smart
person that's given me information
before and then I know the border patrol
I mean I've had meetings with I'm not
going to get too specific here I've had
meetings and by the way you guys know in
low love my head security guy you can
ask him he's been in the meanings with
me and Senior
senior federal judges senior federal
agents so we've had meetings in this
office on Zoom with senior feds quite a
few times giving us information on the
border where the smuggling centers are
we've been down there we've shown the
human smuggling yeah we've shown the
children uh we we go down there and fly
members of you know Congress around in
helicopters I was involved in a group
doing that just yesterday outside
Houston where there's a 200 000 person
city they're building for the illegal
aliens uh and we're going to break all
that video tomorrow on my show at 11 A.M
Central and we're going to have uh
mad maxwell.com
plug for the show what I'm saying is is
that I have so many federal
whistleblowers I can't even talk to them
all and they're always begging me to
cover something begging me to do
something because most the feds are good
people they're just compartmentalized I
mean these federal judges have told me
that they'll have a convicted pedophile
convicted three or four times caught
working in South Texas driving a school
bus for disabled children and and and
molesting them again and then Merrick
Garland the attorney general has the
power over judges and federal
magistrates to not let them in
foreign
[Music]
I'm concerned about it because like you
said then all of a sudden it went
mainstream and they're going oh yeah
we're gonna we're gonna sort of
gradually bring in these lockdowns and
mask mandates so it's almost like
whistleblowers are not necessarily
needed because they don't even seem
concerned because so many of them
operate with complete impunity but I
know you'll be talking about that on
your show tomorrow mad maxwell.tv people
can watch you today and of course
Fridays at 12 p.m Eastern it is
incredible to see uh See you call
another shot like Babe Ruth and point
and people go Ah that's not going to
happen and then two days later it's
almost like you were in Oracle Alex
thanks for taking the time brother
guys thank you so much and it's great to
be working with you we did a two and a
half hour special deep dive on Bill
Gates and the globalists and they're
playing to turn off the resources and
take control of our lives this is the
guy that wants to run your life
everybody that's a mug Club member needs
to go in there and watch that we're
gonna have another special show that uh
we're gonna shoot uh on Thursday uh
that's going to be another Deep dive and
then we're going to start uh doing a lot
of on the ground reporting like we've
done in the past but we're going to be
uploading that as well and so a lot
coming to mug club and it's great to be
working with you guys and thank you so
much for your hard work hey thanks and
we appreciate you doing that work on the
ground that has been Alex Jones ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
I don't know what we ended up talking
about after the okay it's amazing it's
it's who needs The Simpsons he's Alex
Jones for a reason he's Simpson's on
steroids all of a sudden we should talk
about javelins the tanks and pedophiles
at least in East Texas I was thinking
the same thing as you though I'm going
why would the feds talk to the yeah why
would they talk to Alex Jones you know
it's getting out yeah I know huh how do
you how do you it's amazing and he's
right I mean like you said he says the
stuff and then a month later or a week
later yeah and he's always been that way
he's he's been right about it's always
been that way to the point where I'm
going uh I can't even but well I like
the I like the fact that they say
um the government's pointing out we're
only you know for what is two weeks
we're gonna have yeah two weeks they're
cutting and pasting from the propaganda
almost three years ago they're so it is
so transparent they're not concerned Why
are you how do you first of all every
September
everyone gets sick I know that's the
every time you go to school
back to college back to school everyone
gets sick in September that's that's
number one but how do you predict
pandemic didn't we this is why I get
confused I get really pissed so when
fauci's on trial and they're asking all
the questions and they're and and we
went through this was that in Congress
or whatever what happens when they're
caught with their pants down lying what
where where is all this guys nothing
yeah yeah they get they get a raise they
get a promotion or they get to step or
they get their own custom tops card it's
mind-boggling but you know what we can
actually let's talk that's a good
question let's talk about it more we're
also going to be doing life advice if
you're not watching on my club
lottoscar.com I have a hiccup that I'm
trying to swallow Nick depalo September
15th at Rob's comedy Playhouse Buffalo
New York and Jim Brewer September 16th
in Sarasota Florida art Ovation you can
go to jimbrewer.com life advice uh right
here and tomorrow 8 30 Eastern is going
to be the mega that's why the studio is
kind of in disarray we're setting
everything up for the live stream
tomorrow with live fact check the
drinking games there's a lot going on
Nick depalo will be with us thank you
very much YouTube Rumble piss off no
wait sorry the opposite
good
[Music]
foreign